(fire crackling
and wind whistling)
(singing in foreign language)
(rapping in foreign language
with deep bass music)
(dramatic music)
- Let us be honest as Afrikans.
Ghana does not want cocaine
so there are very
strict laws on cocaine.
We've stopped it.
Once you see cocaine,
somebody gets arrested.
Ghana doesn't want
armed robbery.
Once we see armed robbery,
there is something
serious about it.
As a country, we pretend
we do not want e-wastes
but we do not have laws to
stop the second-hand goods
from coming to this country.
It is sheer pretense.
It is sheer hypocrisy.
The things we do not want
as a country, we fight it
and that is our culture.
And that is it, it's about
business, about money.
I mean, the second-hand
market in Ghana is very huge.
This is a country where
we don't produce much,
most of the things we do is
imports, trade, imports,
trade, imports, trade.
Now, as a developing country,
people are beginning to get
interested in,
you know, gadgets.
An unemployed country,
they don't have money
to buy brand new gadgets,
so there is a huge market
for second-hand goods.
(singing in foreign language)
(speaking foreign language)
(game clattering)
- I think as a country
it is not our priority,
we have not been
serious about it
although we know it exists
and we know it is dangerous,
there is no concerted
effort as a country
in addressing this issue.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat percussion music)
(singing in foreign language)
(audience applauding)
- It is we Ghanians,
if we know this is bad
and our leadership
knows this is bad,
what have they done
over the decades?
So we may cite conventions
and speak about it,
it's nice to put on suits
and wear a tie on TV,
even though you know it is
bad, it is affecting Ghanians
deep down in their hearts,
in their daily activities,
what are they doing to stop it?
Nothing.
The leadership of this
country has, over the years,
closed one eye on
that illegality
because stopping it will
cost them some votes.
- It will take Ghanians
working together
to resolve this challenge.
- If our president
goes to sign something
to more or less assign a rating
on e-waste, even if
it's just a convention
that was signed in Geneva,
or Zuki, or Thailand,
or Europe somewhere.
My grandma doesn't
know about it.
She has not gone
to school before.
They are in the majority.
One day you pause this
and things get to
the Ghana Ports.
The authorities of this country,
they charge them
tax on those goods.
If you know those goods are bad,
why are you charging tax on it?
- The countries
that did the best,
they had no natural resources,
no diamonds, no oil.
What did they have?
Fixers.
They had people in
Singapore that were buying
used hard-drives from the
U.S. and repairing them
until they were so good at it
that Western
Digital and Seagate,
they built factories there.
And that's what we want
to see 10 years from now.
- A TV repairman is
like being an engineer.
That's like, they
don't have the choice
to go to MIT to become
a rocket engineer.
They've learned to do
something themselves
by studying the textbooks.
And, with their own hands,
they've fixed the wires,
fixed the circuit boards,
and make something
that somebody in
Africa can now afford.
Now they can watch
the World Cup.
Before, they couldn't.
Now they can get online
and get a g-mail account.
Before, they couldn't.
And you know what?
In the end, the manufacturers
are going to be happy.
Because the more
people in Africa
that can afford to
get on the internet,
the more people in Africa
and South America and India
that can learn to have
a Facebook account,
someday, those people are
going to want a new computer.
(dramatic music)
- The government doesn't have
the audacity, the courage,
the tenacity, to stop
some of these things.
Because, you see, once
you stop it there,
it affects several
thousands of people.
You're going to create a
huge unemployment situation.
If you go to Agbogbloshie,
there are several families
who only put bread
on their table
through some of these things.
They burn them,
looking for copper,
and they tore one aluminum
or one metal or the other.
Any government that
dare say we are stopping
all these things that are
good is afraid to lose votes,
is afraid to lose that
cost between voters.
That is the issue.
(speaking in foreign language)
- What these are,
are very young people
who also work here on the
downside collecting the e-waste.
Because they are not so strong,
what they do is
to sift the soil.
And they would find some
metals they also go to sell,
and then have some
money to buy some food.
And then they just
weigh it there.
Once they weigh their stuff,
then they take some money.
Another person comes
to buy the rest,
and it is taken to the ports.
It is taken to some companies
that would need copper,
or would need other metal.
(dramatic music)
(speaking in foreign language)
(machine beeping)
- Out of precaution, we
found severe contamination
of the environment around where
the waste has been carried out,
with a whole range of chemicals.
This is similar to
what we've found
at e-waste recycling sites in
some other countries as well.
So we found extremely high
levels of some toxic metals.
Things like lead and
cadmium, and also
a whole complex mixture
of organic chemicals.
Now, many of these
are put in the devices
when they're
manufactured, some of them
are generated when the plastics
in electronics are burned.
A lot of the chemicals
are highly persistent.
They just don't break
down, or break down
very slowly in the environment,
so they'll stay there
for many years to come.
And some of them could even
build up in the food chain.
So this whole
mixture of chemicals
is causing severe
environmental contamination
around where these e-wastes
are being recycled.
(calming peaceful music)
- Somebody discovers
a new problem,
a new environmental problem,
you have to have
a solution to it.
And that's what the Basel
Convention was for me.
It was basically
the international
community's response
to the phenomenon
of waste dumping
from developed countries
and developing countries
where there were no controls,
people didn't even
know what it was,
people didn't know the danger.
And you had this problem.
You had massive amounts
of really hazardous,
dangerous wastes being shipped
from Europe and
the United States
and other developed countries
to Africa, to Eastern Europe,
and just dumped there.
And people were killed,
some people died,
people got diseases, there
was massive pollution,
animals died, rivers and
wetlands were polluted.
So for me, it was
really, at the time,
a solution to make
people aware of this,
that this is really a problem,
that it had to be stopped.
(dramatic music)
- My name is Ugo Vallauri
and I'm one of the co-founders
of The Restart Project,
which we started in
London in June, 2012.
And we've been running
now for over two years,
for over 70 events
just in London alone,
and approximately
close to 50 events
outside of London
and internationally,
still in the past two years.
The Restart Project
is a social enterprise
which we created in
London with the objective
of changing people's
relationship with technology.
Learning how to repair things,
and by doing that, learning
more how to have control
over the digital devices
that are multiplying
in our everyday lives.
The Restart Project was set
up with a very simple slogan
that I think is valid for
people everywhere in the world
and that slogan is, "Do
not despair, just repair."
I think, sometimes,
we underestimate
the powerful reality of
taking something apart,
learning how it works,
learning what the fault was,
and being personally empowered,
together with other individuals
that help you to put
it back together,
plug it in, and see
it working again.
And, in a sense, our attachment
to that device becomes
much stronger afterwards.
And a lot of people
end up struggling
with things that
they used to love
and that they associate
personal memories to
and they can't find
a way to fix them
so they just put
them in a corner
of their house and move on.
But it is so inspiring
to see people
learn a new skill and learn how,
instead of wasting stuff,
they can give it a new life.
(children singing "O
Come All Ye Faithful")
- The problem is not telling
us the system is dangerous.
Every Ghanian knows the ones
who are bending these things
and are consuming them, it
is dangerous to my health.
Adults need to go
to school to know
that, ah, those
fumes I am inhaling
is dangerous to my health.
Immediately, it makes
you start coughing.
It's toxic, you can see it.
You don't need to be a doctor.
We know it is bad, that we know.
(radio playing
slow country music)
(dramatic music)
- What we did was, took
three of the leaders,
The Three Musketeers,
Yaro, Awal, and Razaq,
and said, hey you
guys, take four or five
of these piles of wires that
you were gonna burn today,
put them in sack,
and bring them up
to Tamale with us next week.
Because we're gonna
do an experiment.
We're gonna show you something.
Because it turns out that,
one of the laptop technicians
is from the same
village as them,
and his dad's a metal smith.
Sule, Camodian's dad,
and Sule had these ideas
when we said, hey, we need
to do something constructive.
He said, hey, what
if we cut the wire
in a way that it
doesn't burn it,
and my dad can hire some people
to help him make it into jewelry
and we can tell people,
hey, when you buy this,
instead of donating money
or having your taxes
go to a million dollar
shredding machine
that you can have
a direct impact?
And I don't know if
it's going to work,
but it's cool to see
an African technician
bring his idea to the table.
(dramatic music)
- In the north, they
don't have ways and means
to be able to keep
that for themselves.
Most of them you see here,
they don't have parents.
Some have single parents,
some don't at all.
So, due to this, they
were brought here
to be able to work and
send some money home,
and also feed themselves.
But when they come
here, they find out
that here is not what
they have been told
or who people told them to be.
So now, they are here
and they are sleeping
over here on this dump site,
what we call the e-waste.
So they sleep here always,
both afternoon,
morning, and evening.
They eat over here, they
do everything over here
by bending this scrap.
So when they bend this scrap,
they bend something small,
like one Ghana CD, two Ghana CD,
up to, let's say, five Ghana CD.
Those who want to
become mechanics,
those who want to
become seamstress.
The boys run from there,
because there's no
job in the north.
So when they are here,
the things that they bend,
it's mostly the copper,
and then they sell it
to make some small money.
It goes in the north.
It is like family
and, let's say,
if it's not raining,
you can go to the farm.
(dramatic music)
♪ They come
♪ Prove my guilt
♪ Trouble comes now I
know where to be found ♪
♪ They search and see
I'm gone with the wind ♪
♪ I feel like a winner
in this life of sin ♪
♪ He has my heart
♪ Makes me feel so bad to see
♪ my little brothers
and sisters suffer ♪
♪ In the scorching heat
♪ Can't get food to eat
♪ Mr. Wicked Man doesn't
suppose this is better ♪
♪ How do you sleep at night?
♪ Cala sa superpower
♪ Mama got us a key
♪ Ain't got no tune
♪ Papa goes to school
to once again get food ♪
♪ Misleading the lake with
the dune sand trucks ♪
♪ Drive them all to insanity
♪ With their mad reality
(bustling village noises)
(chicken crows)
- As you can see,
the flag down there,
that is where I used to sleep.
Where we're heading to,
where you can see the
Ghana flag hanging.
That is where, when I
came, I'd usually sleep.
It was a place we used
to spread the bugs around
and then get something
little to just cover yourself
when you sleep.
I stayed at that four bottom
trait before I was outside.
I was sleeping
around this water.
It was really deeper
than this and I think now
because it's no easier
to stick in place,
the place has been filled up.
As you can even see,
an example of the water
still lying down.
So you can see there
was a lot of water here,
and we were staying just
exactly up at that place.
You can see how bad it
was, as it was then,
sleeping outside with
all the mosquitoes.
The inside of this area smells.
People used to die,
friends used to die.
It was something that
was running through
my mind, my brain.
I was very barren,
I was looking,
when would I leave here,
and praying to leave.
Then we began
breaking computers,
breaking e-wastes, my TV, just
to pick copper, pick metal.
I'm now happy today, no
more breaking computers
just to pick parts,
or pick e-wastes,
but today, I'm now
using a computer.
(singing in foreign language)
- So you, if you're saying
you want to do something,
have it mind, this
is what I want to do.
Even if you're not qualified,
you can still go
back and write easy.
You can use that said figure
to apply for something,
you understand?
And you go into an institution,
ask their qualifications
and then their tuition.
Definitely ask for forms.
With the forms, they
say it's 20 Ghana.
And I'm sure maybe,
here, you get money
maybe in a week you
can conserve a little.
Maybe in a month, you can
win, acquire the tuition.
Don't wait for help.
You can only try climbing,
then ask for a push.
When you try climbing, then
people can help push you.
You can start with nothing,
but you must try
to help yourself.
A little in a week, alright?
♪ I'm a real survivor
♪ I'm gonna stay alive
♪ Too hot not to hurt
♪ Nowhere to run, I've
got no place to hide it ♪
♪ I'm a real survivor
♪ I'm gonna stay alive today
and another day goes on ♪
♪ Too hot not to work
♪ Nowhere to run
♪ I've got nowhere to hide it
♪ I'm a real survivor
- As a foreigner, you
need to look at e-waste
from all that will
come into the country
are second-hand goods.
Cell phones, electronics, or
even very old cars, or whatnot.
My brother, it goes beyond that.
Go the Virius Albatois where
we slaughter cows and goats.
We use ties, I mean car ties,
in burning those animals.
And this is not a secret,
they don't hide to do it.
You see them just look
for those old, used ties,
put petrol on it, set it
ablaze, and put animals on it
for us to turn it, just
to burn it with the fur,
burn it with their hair.
And this is what we consume.
It is not solely for
the low-class, no.
The ministers also buy
it from their char bus,
and that is how they
skin their meats.
It goes to the restaurants,
it goes everywhere.
There's a day-to-day challenge
of eating what we have seen.
(radio playing upbeat music)
(speaking in foreign language)
- This last week's fire,
one of them was
going by the road
picking the loose wires
and used computer stuff.
So when he was going
around picking them,
he was knocked down by a car.
So he didn't die on the spot,
but the lady who
knocked him with a car
had to rush him to
our tingent hospital,
which is a called a
moving tingent hospital.
But when I went up there, the
doctors didn't attend to him.
And due to that, he died.
He died on the spot.
I actually buried him.
We had to send Pato instead.
We had something that
we call tradition.
So Pato still removed the
fingernails and stuff,
we have to be able to
send him to the mother,
who is the only
family in the north.
The village that he
comes from is Sablulu.
So we have to be able
to carry the remaining
of the body to
Sablulu for the family
to also see and believe.
Because when they
see the remaining,
they know it is true
their son is dead.
Yeah, so because we
don't have the money
to go to the necessary center
where he was not taken
care of, and he had to die.
- What I found is that,
if I went back to Africa
and I found one of my students
taking a laptop and repairing it
by replacing the capacitor,
generating 700 dollars
worth of value in
45 minutes of work,
I would see the most exciting
thing I could imagine.
And right now, the problem is
that a hotel like this one,
with more than 1000 rooms,
they replace televisions, the
big working CRT televisions,
from hotels like this
around the country
and around England.
Thousands of working TVs because
their customers want flat.
Somebody like Joe
Benson in London
sees, hey, suddenly there's
600 working CRT televisions.
He takes them and he sells them,
and if you go there, you
will find those are not
the TVs being filmed with
the kids in the dumps.
The kids in the dumps have
some white monitor from 1995.
That's what's being burned,
but what's happening
is, people are reacting
not to the color of the black
TV or the white monitor,
they're reacting to
the color of the kids.
And it's turned into a
bizarre racial profiling
of the best and
brightest people ever.
And this year, they actually
put a guy in jail for it.
(dramatic music)
- People like Joe
Benson and others
engage in the same
type of business
are actually doing
something very sensible.
Because they're making
sure that people
who cannot afford to
buy a new product,
as he also said, can still
make use of this equipment
and the equipment's
life will be prolonged.
So he is a businessman, and
somebody using common sense
would not pay for
something that is waste.
If something is used, then
re-used, then re-used,
and re-used, and in the
end, there will come a point
where it does become waste.
And there, he said,
when that happens,
there's no recycling
facilities in Africa,
which is also very true.
The traditional notion
that the legislation
like the Basel Convention
is based on is,
to put it in a
simplified manner,
that everything
that's used is waste.
And the reason for
that is, as I said,
that at the time
when the convention
was negotiated,
in the late 1980s,
you did not have
e-waste as a problem.
It's not really clearly defined
what is e-waste and what isn't.
My vision, if that's not
too grandiose of a word,
is really to see a world
where wastes become resources.
(dramatic music)
- Five years ago,
it went insane.
Interpol created a thing
called Project Eden
to start to arrest
all of the people
who were importing
televisions to Africa.
People like Joe Benson
and hundreds of others,
and my friend Wahan.
And that's where we said,
we've gotta get active.
We formed an association,
Fair Trade Recycling,
to try to create a network
in Africa's tech sector
so that they can
communicate better
to the regulators that
I used to work with
and say, time-out.
And the environmental
community needs to wake up
to the idea of
collateral damage.
That by raising
money in this way
and telling ourselves,
patting ourselves on the back,
that we're the great white
savior saving these people
when actually, if you
arrested 1,000 Joe Bensons,
if you arrested every
Wahad, you would do nothing
to stop the flow of
material into Agbogbloshie
that was important 20 years ago.
(dramatic music)
- The most harmful thing
is the burning of the wire
because of the
dioxins and the toxins
that were created from
when you burned off
all the plastic
to get the copper.
So I thought that was
the best thing to solve
because it's the thing
that has the biggest
impact on the environment,
and the biggest impact
on the people's health
that are doing it.
So the way the
system works is that,
you put wires in the top
here, and then inside
there's a shredder
that shreds it up.
So there's a series of blades
that spin around and
shred up the wiring.
And then it comes out
of the bottom here,
and it comes out as
lots of bits of plastic
and lots of bits of metal.
So that isn't a big mix of stuff
that you have to separate in
two, which is the hard bit.
So shredding up
wire is quite easy,
you don't need anything
too technical to do that.
But then, to separate the
plastic from the metal,
you need to develop
another machine to do that,
which is this machine over here.
Should I bring it over here, or?
(chuckles)
So the way this device works is,
that there's a pump that
sits under the bicycle wheel,
and it pumps water into here,
and it comes out
of holes up here,
and it also causes
this basin to rotate.
What happens is that
all of the material
gets into the water,
but because the copper
is slightly heavier,
it stays on this lip,
and it's carried up the basin
and through the
hole in the center.
But because the plastic
is slightly lighter,
it gets washed away, right out
of the basin and into here.
So then you end up
with all the copper
being collected
in a small bucket
that sits behind
the hole, and then
all the plastic ends
up in the basin.
That's basically it.
I'm happy with it,
as in, it's a system
that's sort of in the works,
but I'm not happy
in terms of the fact
it hasn't actually
been deployed.
It's not something
that's been implemented.
At the moment, it remains a
concept rather than a solution.
So the key is making
sure that money
comes back down into the system
so the person will use cycling.
And therefore, they do
it because they have
a lot more money.
It will fit up to 30% more
money from the cycling.
So I think, really,
you don't need
to explain that
technicality or explain
an environmental
reason for doing it.
It has to be that you explain
a financial reason for doing it.
If you do this, then
you can make more money
than you do at the moment.
And I think that's how
you can convince people
to use Assistant Miners.
(singing in foreign language)
(orchestral music)
- Put your camera
down, picture a troop.
A lot can accomplish this.
You will see many vacals
end up right here.
(imitates explosion
sound) E-wastes.
Should I blame the white man?
No!
Who takes income
tax on that vacal?
The government of Ghana.
Who gives all them the
road-ready license?
The government of Ghana.
Who is sure that, the
government of Ghana.
Why should I blame the white man
who is in this country and
hasn't done anything wrong?
So is this the blame game?
You keep shifting the blame,
but you do not
solve the problem.
Okay, so let's say it
is not anybody's fault,
but the thing that's still here,
if we really want to stop them,
why are we not fighting them?
(somber orchestral music)